errors in your code are unavoidable and
it's important to know when they happen
and get enough information to fix them
quickly
writing out error logs is easy enough
but how do you send those messages to
stackdriver
let's look at how to get your logs and
stackdriver and what you can do from
there
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
there are multiple ways to log errors in
google cloud you can use logging and set
your log severity to error
or you can use error reporting to get
powerful tracking and analysis
capabilities
today i want to show you how both work
and help you understand how to choose
between them
let's start with a simple example of a
web server written in node.js
the app encounters an error so something
has gone wrong but we don't have any
other details
you'll want to write those details to an
error log but there are a few ways to do
that
your first option is to use the cloud
logging library directly
however it requires you to explicitly
build each log entry by manually
specifying your metadata before writing
it this can be useful if you need this
level of fine grained control over the
data you're writing
but could be tedious if you're doing a
lot of logging more commonly you may
choose to either use the bunion or
winston logging libraries
to use the bunion library simply add it
to your code create a new instance of
the logger
and then write error logs using the dot
error method using the winston library
is very similar
create a new instance of the logger and
write error logs using the diary method
in both cases structured logs will be
written to stackdriver logging
the main difference between the bunion
and winston libraries is the verbosity
of the resulting logs
the bunion log messages contain a lot
more metadata potentially making them
more useful
but resulting in higher log volumes and
possibly higher costs
consider both of these factors when
choosing your logging approach so now we
have a way to log basic app errors in
our node server
from here we can do things like create
log based metrics to be notified when
these errors occur
but what happens if these errors are
actually exceptions that contain stack
traces
if you log an exception the full stack
trace is available in the log entry
making it easy to understand exactly
what happened however it's still hard to
get your information across your
exceptions
this is where you can use stackdriver
error reporting which automatically
identifies exceptions
groups and based on the stack trace and
creates a histogram showing you when
these exceptions occur
there's no additional setup needed to
get error reporting to identify errors
with stack traces in them
you can look at the details of each
error to see the full stack trace and
the individual log
records that contain that error you can
then subscribe to notifications to know
when new errors are detected in your
project
and link errors to bugs to keep track of
errors you fix over time
note that you can actually use the air
reporting client to send errors directly
to air reporting
even if they don't have stack traces if
you do that they're also written to
stackdriver logging along with
other logs you write allowing you to
read the benefits of both logging
and error reporting you have multiple
options for writing errors and
exceptions to stackdriver logging
and using error reporting can be a good
way to get a better understanding of how
and when crashes happen in your app
without giving up the benefits of
logging
thank you for joining me today and come
back soon for more this is the
stackdoctor
stay healthy out there
you